when did you know you were going to be a
writer glenn i was really little i was
like nine or ten years old um i actually
at first i wanted to be a fictional
character i distinctly remember wanting
to be james bond or the hardy boys or
sherlock holmes it was mostly detectives
and spies
and at some point around 10 or 11 years
old i it occurred to me that
there were people who wrote those peop
those people that i wanted to be and
that life i wanted to live and i rec i
sort of shifted an inch over but i've
never really stopped
wanting to be
fictional
so that's how writing is for me it's
just an attempt to be fictional at all
times how did you discover that oh wait
there are authors here and and
there was a there was a magazine called
show magazine at the back in the 1960s
and there was an interview with ian
fleming who wrote james bond and he
wrote an article about how he wrote
james bond and it blew my mind because
there was this person saying how you
could create this world with these
people in it and i was like that's what
i want to be
and then um harriet the spy
harriet the spy was a huge influence on
me uh she wanted to be a writer and she
um she explored the world around her and
i was like that's that's what the job i
want that's the life
did your parents try to talk you out of
it or were they encouraging no no my
parents were very supportive i was very
lucky in that way they were scared they
were nervous
um but it wasn't like this was an
outrageous thing to do it was just
we hope that you can survive oh and and
there were times when that was
in question
um
they helped me out financially a lot
especially in the
many years after college when i was not
making any money
um
i've been very lucky that way i had a
lot of support
can you explain how anxiety almost
ruined your writing career
it almost stopped it from starting
i was a terribly terribly anxious young
person
still i'm very anxious i just actually
writing has become sort of the way i
counter anxiety it's one of the few
things that's totally within my control
and
control is what helped having the
feeling of having something in your
control is what helps anxiety so um
being able to go into a fictional world
or create a world or
follow a story in your mind
was one of the few things that would
prevent me from feeling anxious and yet
when i tried to write them down i was
always very self-critical
it always seemed more complicated than
just making it up in your head to
actually get it down on on paper
was was very difficult and so i started
wanting to write when i was 10 or 11
and i would write outlines or plans for
things and write beginnings of things
but i wouldn't be able
to actually finish them um and i could
not figure out why
the answer was anxiety the answer was
not having a process
um and and it took about 10 15 years of
struggling with that and having writer's
block and
and
being talented i mean i could think of
this stuff i would write good stuff when
i wrote but i would write very very
rarely and it would be very upsetting
and one of the things i had to teach
myself which is what i now try to teach
others is the importance of having a
reassuring process a routine a very
mechanical way of doing the work so that
there's no anxiety involved because it's
just like if you were a musician you
would practice your instrument
regardless of quality regardless of of
importance you just
run your finger over the keys over and
over and over again and if you do that
as a writer if you push yourself to just
write even if it's bad if you push
yourself to just get used to the
experience of stopping and starting and
starting and stopping every day for days
and days and days eventually it becomes
so
comforting and familiar that you can
actually do the creative stuff the
creative stuff comes after the process
a lot of this actually reminded me i
eventually ran into stanislavski's
writing about actors
and i recognize that it's the same thing
i actually think of it as method writing
because
the idea of an actor having to go out on
a stage and be able to summon up an
emotion on cue
every night when it was in theater and
you had to do it every night
was a struggle that anyone would have a
problem doing and so the stanislavski
tried to work out a process a method by
which you can create a
a very
mysterious thing called emotion
on cue even if it's not yours even if
you don't feel it and that's essentially
what a writer does there's just nobody
looking but you have to sit down at your
desk and somehow transport yourself into
a fictional world into a created place
with people who are not you and you have
to feel these feelings and imagine this
stuff that has to come out of you from
you know not where people don't know
where creativity comes from you know
when you get it you know when it's
happening but you don't know how it
happens
and you can't so what you can know
is if i create this ritual this routine
by which i'm going to always open the
same type of notebook or i'm going to
have the same format i'm working in and
i'm going to understand the mechanics of
writing the idea of character and story
and people taking action
and if you get all those things and you
apply them to whatever you're writing
over and over you'll eventually become
so comfortable with the process that
you'll become creative and after many
many years where i would just panic
every time i had to write
now i actually find that writing is the
thing that keeps me from panicking about
life
and that i'll find myself every day if i
don't write
i get nervous
but
if i do write or if i if i trust the
process
it will
absolutely take away the anxiety i can
you can't guarantee much about the arts
but i can guarantee that practice and
exposure to the process and creating a
ritual is almost always guaranteed to
make your art better
and so it sounds like that definitely
didn't come right away from
you you it took years because you you
were enrolled in school and then you
left
i was i was very lucky i got into yale
university on uh there was a freak
moment
when they were accepting very creative
people without great grades um it was in
the mid-1970s and the world was in
turmoil and things were not as stressed
as they are now i guess all i know is i
was good at english but not much else
and i applied to a bunch of schools and
i got into yale
and
so i went i didn't actually even want to
go to college i just wanted to be a
writer and i thought this is just a
waste of my time but i got in i can't
not go
and i went and it was a
cool experience but by the end of the
first year i was struggling with my
writing and i blamed college i now know
what i just told you which is that i had
been struggling with my writing before
college and i was going to struggle with
it after college but for that moment i
was like ah if i only didn't have this
college thing i would be able to write
which is crazy because like i had you
know four classes and i didn't have that
much to do
but um
dropped out uh in my the beginning of my
sophomore year and i called my parents i
actually said to them would you take the
money you're paying college and just
give it to me to pay for an apartment so
i can be a writer and they said no
oh okay they're not insane they're
supportive but not crazy okay and they
said but you know if you want to come
home come home so i came home and i
lived in the basement
and i just tried to write and all the
problems i had that i blamed on college
they were still there when college
wasn't and i was i tried everything it
would be like oh if i only had this
music to play then i would be able to
write and i would go out and buy a
record and then oh if i only read this
book i would be prepared to write this
book
and
a whole year went by like that i just
like terribly stressed and never getting
anything done and and trying every day
and feeling
terrified because i screwed up college
and now i had nothing
um
and
one day i was trying to write a play
and i ended up
writing the opening of a movie version
of the play i was reading william
goldman's um scripts and and novels and
william goldman is such an amazing and
influential writer
and his style of screenwriting is so
catchy that i just thought i can't write
this play but i can imagine the movie
version of the play i'll write it in his
style so i wrote about six or seven
pages of the opening and it was the
first thing i had written in about a
year
and it
it sort of broke open the gates
to the concept of this what i was saying
about having a process just learning how
to
understand who the characters are and
what the scene they're in is and if you
learn to think in scenes
then you just write that one scene
um
so that was that i got six pages written
in a year
and i said i better go back to college
because i need something to cover the
next three years while i try and figure
out how to get over this i went back to
college this is a terribly long story
okay what did you live in i lived in new
york oh okay um and i so it wasn't far
from new haven and i they they um they
took me back
um with some caveats
and then i had a couple of years when i
was going to college and trying to
overcome this writing problem which i
was working towards but honestly it
wasn't until after that so we're talking
now years and years later i'm still
having a hard time with getting all the
creativity
out
and
i was trying to write a novel
and i was working as an office temp i
worked as an office temp for
12 years on and off after college before
i start to make a living as a writer and
um
during the many years of office tempting
i was writing at different people's
desks every day i would have a new job
every day sometimes and i would lug my
writing around in a little briefcase
and i had to learn how to write in the
spaces when no one was bothering me at
temp jobs so like someone would say go
xerox something at xerox and i'd have
like half an hour nothing to do and
that's when i could write
and so that was like the antithesis of a
good writing space you know i'm in a
public office and i have a little
notebook
and i learned that if you just think
about the scene you're in you just think
about the moment that this character is
trying to accomplish this one thing that
they are doing because people only do
one thing at a time characters are only
doing one thing at a time so you only
need to write that one thing and so
i specifically remember there was a
scene of a character
the story was that he had sublet his
apartment to a serial killer
he was a wannabe screenwriter and he
just discovered a body in his apartment
and he goes
to call the police this is back in the
80s so it was he had to go to the pay
phone on the corner
and i had to describe what it's like to
run to a pay phone in the corner in the
rain and tell the police that you'd
sublet your apartment to a serial killer
and i just tried to imagine what it was
like for a struggling screenwriter
and i had i had at the time holes in my
shoes because they had worn through and
i'd put cardboard in them so i described
what it was like when the rainwater came
through the hole in your shoe and what
it was like to try and explain to the
police why you would sublet your
apartment to a serial killer i had not
done that part but i was in the moment
and that's really what it's about
thinking about the scene and being in
the moment and understanding what a
character is trying to accomplish and
why there's an obstacle to that
in this case the obstacle was shame
the fact that he was a little ashamed
that he had gotten himself into the
position um
and so that's it character objective
obstacle scene
um there's somebody who wants something
and they're trying to do it but there's
something in their way if you have that
then you can always find that just that
little piece
then you can write
and i remember writing the scene and
going wow
i did it the thing that was here is down
there
and i started to learn to practice that
process
the process of
thinking in scenes of understanding that
you're not writing the whole story
you're just in this moment with this
character
and that was the beginning of teaching
myself
that process
and
it still took a long time but that's
that's what i learned that's how i
survived and that's what i'm trying to
tell people now
and do you think by
the fact that you had just a quick
amount of time half hour and you knew
too probably people in the office might
be watching or whatever that you there
were no excuses well i need to organize
this and dust this before i start going
oh yeah when i was in high school and i
was like i'm going to be a writer but i
can only write if i have nothing else to
do all day
i mean
even when you're a full-time
professional writer you have other
things to do all day you never get a
whole day free um
so yeah i had this irrational sense that
i had to have the right kind of music
and the right typewriter which actually
did make a difference and um
and
now i was in the exact opposite of that
i was at a different office every week
and
god knows somebody could come up to me
at any moment and ask me to do something
that i hated and
and that's when i began to recognize
that all my insistence on what i thought
was the writer's process
um was actually making it harder
and that when i started to recognize
that if you think in scenes and if you
understand what the character wants and
if you know all of that stuff that
method acting for writers
you can you can do it anywhere anytime
which was good because i had to do it
anywhere at any time
um and that's really actually a very
valuable thing for anyone who wants to
be a professional now because most
professionals are going to be working
on shows not movies they're not going to
be writing at home and sending it in
they're going to be in a room
and you got to be able to deal with
people coming around you and with orders
being given and things being changed and
the more that you can get a strong
process a sense that somebody says to
you
a guy's on a bus and he's got a duck in
his bag go and you have to write a scene
the more that you can teach yourself
that skill that tool of being able to
imagine a scene understanding that
someone needs to do something
and then
getting used to the flow of just putting
something down imagining it and grabbing
it in in a form that you can get onto a
paper
that's the most valuable skill i think i
if you ask any showrunner i think
they're going to say i really want
someone that i can say
this weird thing just was demanded of us
you need to do it go
and they come back next you know in an
hour with a scene that's really valuable
and that's what office temping taught me
so everyone should go out there and
become office steps
and would you was there like a temporary
agency that you would check in with and
they would give you an assignment yeah
it was called payson people they're long
gone but i'd say
um interesting it was it was sweet there
was a very small office it wasn't one of
the big ones and um but they had they
would every week i would call in and say
where am i working this week um and
sometimes it was like thursday or at
this place friday or at this place um
and sometimes it's like you're not
working this week
um but
for much of 10 years that's what i did
did anyone pressure you to or you know
did they offer you a full-time job
because sometimes if you're a temp they
go i like that guy yeah
you know eventually there was um at
about the nine year mark
i did actually take one of the jobs as a
full-time job the people were lovely and
they knew i was a writer and i didn't i
was like
don't if you can't handle the fact that
i'm going to be writing every free
minute you know don't don't hire me um
but we worked it out and i so i worked
for because the benefits helped a lot
and also actually at that time i was
trying to learn how to do diy filmmaking
and
a
small eight millimeter video had just
started and i had i had gotten some
eight millimeter video equipment i
wanted to make features on eight
millimeter radio as uh practice just i
wanna make a practice movie
um and i thought like in theater you do
a workshop you don't just send the play
out into the world you do practice
workshops
and i thought why don't we do that for
movies
so um i used my office after hours i got
permission to uh to shoot in the office
i did a whole
corporate espionage drama
about the snack industry oh wow yeah a
lot of insider yeah there's a yeah it's
a brutal
a throw yeah
and were you riding on the subway were
you taking the subway i was writing on
stuff i wasn't writing on the subway
i was i was absorbing the world in so
many ways sure
through every orifice oh yeah um but but
uh no i i
i tended to write either
um at desks or um at home in the morning
before like i wake up at like four and
write for an hour before getting ready
to go
and did anyone question you and say well
what are you doing with this note what
is this notebook that you're oh yeah
well everyone is like oh he's a writer
yeah everyone knew that and there wasn't
a harry at the spy thing where it's like
what are you writing about us
um but there was there was a sense of
like he's not really
at the time was called a secretary
um
which i was
um yeah no people understood that i was
trying to get out of what i was doing
and to be something else and that was
generally looked well upon people people
didn't give me a hard time
can you talk more about the fears you
had
and how did you know they weren't really
fears when it came to your writing
especially when you were starting out
that's interesting because really
i believe they were fears i think that
the things that people are afraid of in
writing
they should be afraid of you know you
should and if if you're expecting to
make a living as a writer and you're
afraid that you won't that's a very
legitimate fear because the odds are you
won't
and in fact i think one of the most
important things that i would advise
is
plan
for the thing you fear
if you're really afraid that you won't
make a living as a writer and you want
to be a writer start to plan for how
you're going to be a writer when you
don't make a living at it because i ran
into that
often
even after i was a professional writer
because even when you're a professional
in the union
a highly paid writer it can dry up it
can go away things can change
and
the important thing that you want to do
is think first of all would i stop
writing
if i couldn't make a living at it if so
i don't know that you're going to
be a very happy and be a writer because
you you need to be able to want to do it
no matter what and then
okay so i will
be a writer and work early in the
morning before my job as a pharmacist or
i will be a writer and be as i was an
office temp for 12 years or i will be a
writer and live with my family for the
rest of my life whatever it is you know
there's no right or wrong way to do this
there's no actual path
and so you've got to figure out what
makes sense for you and one of the most
important things about that is to
recognize what you're afraid of and try
and plan
for the reality of it if it's going it
could happen you know and and i think
that that actually is what helps a lot
is to say well
all right if i don't make it in
hollywood would i still keep writing and
the answer should be yes it may not be i
keep writing scripts or maybe i'll write
scripts for podcasts that i can produce
myself or i'll write for theater or i'll
make graphic novels whatever it's going
to be
face the fear and be realistic about it
that that was actually what got me
through
um
that that big fear am i going to be able
to do this
there are so many fears to being an
artist aren't there because i was just
thinking that's one but then there's the
fear of am i any good maybe i'm not good
enough and once again the answer has to
be well you're going to be as good as
you're going to be i mean
being afraid of it is not going to make
you better
so you might as well just be how you are
and see where that lands you
you can't actually change many things
there's a lot of things that make it
easier or harder for each of us and
every one of us is different
and for me
the fear of you know will this be
accepted will this be liked at a certain
point it's probably better to look at
that fear and say
would i keep writing this even if
everyone hated it and if you can find
something that you would write then
that's probably the thing you should
write
find a way to do the thing that you do
no matter what
um
that's that the because the rest of the
fears for most of us like nobody's going
to cut your hands off if you write badly
you know i mean except in certain places
probably right
but hopefully for those of us who are
not living there
um
you know it's
these are nice problems to have and
artists should take a deep breath and
recognize that you know the the worst
thing that could happen is you don't
make a fortune oh gee you know if you
write operas or poems you would never
even occur to you screenwriters have
this weird idea that they're supposed to
be rich and famous
um that is not actually an artist's lot
most uh
99.9
of screenwriters are not rich and famous
99 of working screenwriters are not even
rich you know it's it's and certainly in
the the scale of what we think of as
that percentage of of that's what a
screenwriter is
um
most screenwriters don't get to choose
what they work on
um and and honestly what you're doing is
balancing you're saying
i want to get paid for writing
but i also want to write what's in my
head well you're not going to get to do
both of those most of the time if you
write what's in your like i wrote i was
a working screenwriter for 25 years and
non-stop great jobs exciting i almost
was never writing a project that i
conceived of i was being hired by people
who wanted my talents and my skills for
their project and that was paying the
rent and then you know the best day job
you'll ever have and some of the most
wonderful experiences i've ever had but
i was not writing what i could imagine
so i had to do that on the side almost
none of those projects went anywhere
people would read them and say wow
that's great we can't make that
so you know that's success
that's you know is that is that the
picture that you all have out there of
your success no everyone has the success
picture of
those two or three writers that we see
interviewed who are like oh yeah well i
decided i was going to do this project
and i called them up and i told them i
was doing it and they gave me a million
dollars and i went and wrote it
that's just not how that's you know
that's winning the lottery that's
getting hit by lightning being born into
the royal family you know if if you're
lucky enough that that happens great but
most of us should plan
for the thing we fear
and were your fears greater
at that time to
make a living as a writer or would you
even get another temp job because you
know with the damping sometimes you
don't know if you're going to be working
from week to week or hi we don't need
you anymore and you're like okay did i
do something you know and
which fear was greater at that time
that's actually a great question because
it brings up the issue of
sustainability um and by which i do not
mean you know we recycle our projects i
mean you have to be able to have a
sustainable life to be an artist a
creative person of any type and so you
need to be able to separate those and
say
i need to deal with the fear of not
paying the rent and not having food and
not having a good relationship and all
those life things that are very
important they have nothing to do with
your work and your work should not be
making the save on those you should not
be saying
i have a crappy relationship but one day
i'm going to be such a famous writer
that they'll love me anyway that's a bad
plan have a good life and then write
have a life that you can live whether or
not you ever become a rich and famous
writer and and if that is a small life
good whatever as long as it's a
sustainable life as long as you can take
care of yourself then you can apply
yourself to the process of writing an
artist
they're an artistic problem the problems
of am i good enough is this meaningful
enough all those things let alone will
it make any money
which is not really entirely an artistic
problem is a separate thing that you do
when you have the space and the health
to do it
you first have to take care of yourself
you have to have a place to live and a
routine by which you can live fairly
reliably and hopefully with some good
mental health take care of that first
don't be in debt don't put off all the
things of your life until you you know
oh i'll take care of that when i'm when
i'm successful
um no one's ever successful enough to
take care of that
that has to come first and then you make
a space for your work and you'll deal
with each artistic problem like what is
this scene about or is this a good idea
that i feel like committing a year to
those are artistic problems but they
have nothing to do they shouldn't be how
you decide whether or not you're going
to pay your rent
if you get lucky i mean honestly once
you know if you get into the union and
you become a professional writer you're
still basically not going to be
asking that question you're going to be
asking how do i get this job that
someone else has done the creative work
on and i want to work on their project
because except for
a small teeny number of people who are
show runners or people who are writing
features which is a very small number
now you're mostly working on a staff
that's a job it's a job at a corporation
a great job but often a great
corporation and it's really cool
but it's not an artistic problem
artistic problems should be solved with
artistic things and life problems should
be definitely solved with life things
not with artistic solutions
can you tell us the reasons why being a
screenwriter is impossible
yeah absolutely
that actually
in many ways i would advise
no one to be a screenwriter it is
by far one of the dumbest arts to try
and be in other than maybe a large scale
architecture
the first thing about screenwriting is
you're never getting to finish the work
in other words you get to finish the
script but it's not available to an
audience until it's made by other people
so basically you're creating something
in order to give to a bunch of other
people so they'll create another thing
and frankly a different thing the thing
that's based in your script is a
production and it will change in many
ways
um so if you really are like i can
totally picture this movie in my head
and that's why i'm writing it
get over it it will never ever be like
that even in the greatest of
circumstances where things are better
than you want it will never be as you
imagine but honestly i believe that's
the creative process itself when you
imagine a script it actually comes out
differently than you first imagined it
or what you think the process of
transforming anything into a concrete
work out of an abstract thought
changes it
and honestly when a reader reads it
it's going to change again because when
you say
he wore a red tie they're going to
picture a different red tie that you're
picturing
and you have to be able to accept that
you have to be able to accept that the
script is a
a piece of a project that you will not
have any control over so that's number
one is unless you really like that
process of doing something for other
people to work from it's frustrating
um and i know actually a lot of writers
get
very irritated at actors and directors
which is too bad because they should be
more respectful of the other arts but
they're like they didn't say that like i
thought they should like i know how that
line should go and that's not how it
works the line goes how it goes in their
mouth the actor has to be free to act
the way they would act it and if you're
depending on them saying it exactly the
way you imagined it which is frankly not
on the page
it's not going to happen so writing
screenwriting is more frustrating than
most types of writing but then
not only that among most types of
writing you have less control because
you don't own the copyright to your work
if you're a novelist or a playwright or
any other kind of writer you own your
work they can't somebody may
put pressure on you we you know we won't
publish it unless you change it but they
actually can't change it if you write a
script and you sell it to a company for
various reasons having to do with the
ability to unionize back in the 30s
screenwriters gave up their right to own
their creative work which means when you
hire on to write something
they can fire you and have someone else
rewrite it and you cannot do anything
about it and that always sounds like oh
that'll be fine i'll live with that it
hurts
everyone gets fired everyone gets
rewritten most of my career was
rewriting other people and i had to be
aware of the fact that somebody out
there is grinding their teeth and
cursing my name when if i do well
so screenwriting is just a tough
business
then
you get to the fact that
for most writers now you're going to be
working on a staff of a show which means
it's not even your idea you are one of a
bunch of people contributing ideas and
the actual writer of the show the
creator the showrunner is going to be
saying
yes to that no to that that line is good
that line is good we'll put them
together
you may
get creative satisfaction you may be
doing
grunt work you may also i mean on a
feature i wrote
there was an introductory scene of a
character
that i
just hated the way the producers wanted
this character to be introduced they
they thought she was cute and i thought
she was reprintable
and i kept saying do you really want her
to say that and they're like yeah we
think it's funny and i was like
i didn't have an h i had to write the
scene the way they asked for it or i
would be fired or someone else would be
hired to replace or rewrite that scene
that's not
what most people picture as being an
artist it's not what most people picture
as being a writer
but i can go on
the number of reasons that you shouldn't
be a screenwriter are enormous
the reasons that most people want to be
screenwriters are misleading first of
all they think and it's true you are
very very highly paid if you are a
working screenwriter um in the unions in
the studio system the network system um
that is a very small percentage of the
people who are
trying to be writers so it's like saying
i want to be a baseball player
and you're imagining i'm going to be
major league
most people are not going to be major
league the question is would you stop
playing baseball then and
i i can't imagine i can't imagine saying
i want to be an artist but only if
they'll pay me first
that's that's not how generally arts
should work
um most people imagine that
screenwriters have a uh get to people
come to the writer because honestly and
this is a problem of the screenwriting
industry um you know the everyone who
teaches you know they're all saying like
it all begins with the script the script
is so important and you get all these
actors and directors they're saying like
you know and it's true they choose a
good script to work on it's like we
couldn't do this without the script and
wannabe screenwriters are like i'm so
important and i promise you you're not
they are going to change your work they
are going to misinterpret your work
that's just part of the job you are
providing a beginning to someone else's
creative process
and
so
that's a hard thing to almost every
screenwriter i know is looking for a
creative outlet
they're looking for they're writing
novels on the side or plays or they're
painting or whatever
and you wouldn't think that that's what
being a successful screenwriter is but
truthfully
it is it's a it's a job it's a glorious
job and when it works right you have
these amazing experiences where talented
people take your work and they like your
art and they do stuff and it works and
then it goes out to a big audience and
that's a little tiny slice of the
experience
the things i've had made
were amazing there are only
two three percent of what i actually
worked on
most of what i worked on no one will
ever hear of it's trapped in some
company's vault somewhere or in my
drawer because no one bought it and i'm
talented i'm good i'm successful i'm in
the union i'm highly paid and
most of what i write is rejected
so
yeah be a painter if you can because
at least you get done you have the
finished painting
but the flip side of that so that i
don't just discourage the heck out of
everybody
the flip side is if you get good at it
you learn certain skills about narrative
and character that are
invaluable no matter what else you try
to do creatively if you want to be a
director it's great to know what
screenwriting really is what a scene and
a character really are
it's very important to understand how
much the character's
motivation the character's goal their
the thing they're trying to do
that's crucial and if you're writing a
novel it's just as important and if
you're writing a graphic novel or a
video game whatever it is
those basic ideas about a character
wanting something and having a difficult
time getting it that is the center of
any kind of narrative creativity and
screenwriting pushes that harder than
most if you can learn it in
screenwriting you can do it anywhere so
it's sort of good to learn to be a
screenwriter because then you've got a
skill set if you decide to work in video
games
great you're going to be really really
set
and when you were temping in new york
city were you attempting to be an author
or it was when you wrote that play and
then you saw it was sort of
goldman-esque and you thought
let's do screen no ever since i was like
a kid i
when i see something i want to do it
like
paint i was painting for a while i was
drawing i was i was writing plays um i
was trying to direct movies i was trying
to write movies on super 8 silent film
which is
means i had to actually learn how to
make silent movies so i like to say i
came up in silent film
it was in the 1970s but that was all
they had then if you were going to make
if you're a high school student you want
to make a movie they had eight
millimeter home movie cameras
i would make silent movies
um i tried to write novels because i
love novels
plays because i love plays i i have a
dangerous
desire to do absolutely anything i see
so no i was i was always doing all of it
and i would sort of shift my focus
depending on what was practical when i
was in high school
i got tired of silent movies it was
frustrating to not have any dialogue but
high school they had plays so i started
to write plays
high school and college i did plays i
got out of college
i was sort of thinking of writing plays
sort of thinking of writing novels but
screenwriting i thought that would pay
for all of them if i could get
screenwriting jobs i could afford to do
everything else
and then for 12 years i was in office
temp and couldn't afford to do anything
except right in my off time
but the theory always was i was going to
do
it all and screenwriting was just the
most lucrative which is what everybody
thinks and and you know yeah for the
major leagues it's very lucrative for
the rest of us it's not and you should
really want to do it you should love
doing it even if no one pays you
i'm wondering if being an office temp
for the 12 years that you did it and
then doing the writing on the side or in
free time
fueled you because if you'd had a more
comfortable job where maybe money wasn't
an option and trying to book work
maybe you would have given up on the
screenwriting
i don't think i
just personally the way i'm built i
would have i i frequently gave up on
jobs
rather than than have them interfere
with my what i thought was my career
but i do think that it is
i think that life can really challenge
people trying to be artists that the
demands of real life
it's hard it is hard to build a way to
get some time and to feel it's worth it
when it's an abnormal thing to do it's
not it most people aren't doing it and
most people's lives don't require it
most people have
perfectly fine lives without writing a
novel or a screenplay or doing you know
whatever it is that that an artist wants
to do
and and i think it's important to
recognize that you are
doing something
a little offbeat
and that the most important thing i
think you can do is find a way to
comfortably do it
in
the spaces you have to do it in whatever
they are
there are some people who would rather
work for six months and then take two
months off and have the two months to
really work um and other people would
rather work an hour a day
or every other weekend or whatever it is
you have to you have to look at yourself
you have to see what's productive for
you there's no right or wrong um the the
novelist seminar as french mystery
novelist
thriller novelist he used to write in
intensely short bursts he would he would
plan out a novel and then reportedly he
had a separate house built in his
backyard because he could and he would
go to this other house
and he would not talk to his family they
would drop the meals at the front door
and for like two weeks and he wrote
short novels um he would be like don't
bother me i'm writing and he would go in
and then he would
come out with a novel couple weeks later
and then he would live his life and then
next time around he would go back in
that's fine there's other people who you
know just
like me office temping a half hour here
half an hour there at other people's
desks or
like i happen to be a morning person so
i would get up extra early and work in
the morning before work but don't
discount
the amount of
pressure
that real life puts on your art and i
would say the thing to do is
adapt your art to fit that life you know
if you
um
like throwing all these references
around the painter matisse
when he got older he couldn't stand it
as easily and paint anymore and he ended
up
doing these cutouts he would take paper
and cut out figures and they became
gorgeous artwork called the cutouts
there's a book called jazz and a lot of
other work he stopped painting he
couldn't physically paint anymore he
shifted his creativity to something he
physically could do
that i think is a really good lesson for
everyone it's like
if you
can't
find
the time to do it the way you think you
should like i thought i had to have an
eight-hour free day with a lot of iced
tea and music playing and i found that
it was better to write little tiny
slices even just a sentence or a
paragraph if you keep doing a sentence
or a paragraph you will eventually get
whatever it is you need
if you wait till you have the whole day
free you may never
so that that sort of is what i think you
have to do in the face of that
inevitable conflict
and that conflict even happens when
you're
a professional writer i would run into
the problem of you know i'm working on a
project
a show or a movie or something i had a
project i was dying to do and sometimes
i'd have to like
take a break from my writing job so my
job was writing but i had to stop to
do a little indie film that i wanted to
do and so i didn't take work for
as long as i could afford and then i
would go back to work
everybody has this problem the important
thing
is to really
pay attention to what is productive for
you
if that's writing a little bit at a time
if that's writing for short bursts a lot
whatever works
i just wasn't sure if however painful or
maybe not so painful some of these temp
jobs were i know some tempting can be
great and some can be probably
excruciating
did that fuel you the painful moments to
keep going and also too you're around
people that this is their life
they're like lifers at this company and
did you say i don't want to be that guy
yeah
yeah well
it's sort of i mean
to a certain extent this may that sounds
horrible i generally look around and say
i don't want to be that guy
yeah
but what it did do was inform me about
all the parts of life that i didn't know
to find out what it's like to work in
this type of place and that type of i
worked in a lot of different places
and in fact the first novel i wrote was
about
a wannabe screenwriter who was an office
temp so i guarantee you nothing
nothing gets lost on a an artist who's
making his way in the world you got to
be absorbing all of it and writing it
down
how did you take control of your
creative fate i think recognizing that
the only thing an artist truly controls
is the work itself and that is not an
original thought to me many
far better artists have said it
you can't control
whether your work sells whether it is
popular even
people who have sold and had hits will
find themselves doing something and it
flops that's
just
predictable that that will happen so if
if they can't control it if they can't
guarantee a hit if they can't guarantee
that people like it
how should we
there's no way for anyone to know
how things are going to work out
creatively and the way that you become a
happy artist and a productive artist is
to give up worrying about it you say i
am
gambling i am rolling the dice on this
thing because i like it because i think
it's fun because i think other people
will like it
i think that's a big part of it just
saying i am completing this because i
want it complete it has nothing to do
with whether or not someone else will
like it
you should at the same time
adjust your expectations if you are
writing about a very obscure
topic or in an obscure genre um then
don't expect
a big budget
plan one of the things i had to learn
was
if i want to write something weird and
offbeat write it so that i can do it
myself with a video camera and a couple
of actors that i get together learn how
to do things diy learn how to you know
work within the limits that you
can control and then you're controlling
your creative fight
and then if somebody likes it great if
somebody doesn't like it at least you
did it and you're more likely to do the
next thing better from having completed
work and put it out there and seeing the
response there is nothing like it for an
artist to see people respond to your
work and it's one of the things that
screenwriters get to do very
infrequently
most working screenwriters most of their
jobs they don't get out to the public a
lot of people do drafts of things that
don't get made
now you you
do that less because most people are
working on shows when you work on a show
they don't hire you if they're not going
to make it but um the experience of
doing your work and putting it in front
of an audience starting the work
finishing it and presenting it is the
most important education you can get
there is nothing else that that replaces
it so the more you can do that without
asking someone's permission without
waiting until someone says well this
will make me a lot of money so i will
invest in it because people don't people
don't put money into artworks because
they like them mostly they put money
into artworks because they think it'll
make them more money so if you do
something
that's
good but not profitable
you won't get to make it it's better to
do something that's good and can be made
really really cheaply and then you can
make it nobody can stop you and if you
don't feel like directing it yourself
somebody who does know how to work low
budget will be able to make it
so completing projects is very important
to you is that completing the process
the artistic process is the
best education you can get um if you
can
write 10 scripts and finish them and
ideally at least get a reading of them
but but really the best thing to do is
to shoot them find a way to get someone
to shoot your script
make it shorts
whatever
that will teach you more than any other
education about screenwriting
and if they're bad so what you know do
it in such a way that if you lose your
money
it's not the end of the world
how did you get your first hollywood
writing job it was a
fluke a freak occurrence um i it was
actually a script that i had written 10
years before it was my first script and
i had gotten an agent with my first
script i'd gotten very lucky i knew
someone who knew someone who showed it
to an agent who
picked me up as their client but they
could not get me i there had been a very
small option during the 10 years other
than that
i was office temping and
administrative assistanting and doing
some development work for indie
companies
and i was beginning to think i should
stop i should just because i was
actually planning to become a teacher
like maybe a high school teacher or
college teacher if i could because at
least i would have summer vacations to
write
it was always what can i do to support
my writing that never stopped but the
idea of becoming a screenwriter stopped
because i was like
why keep beating my head against the
wall i had written a bunch of scripts i
had an agent i if i wasn't making it
maybe i should quit
but the the first script i had written
all of my scripts were well liked by the
people who read them they just were like
this is really good we just can't make
it for a billion reasons there's always
a billion reasons why people can't do
things
um but a an independent producer who
really loved one of my scripts and i had
done some rewrites with her um her name
was mae wathridge and she
um took a job at tribeca films when it
was just starting and um
she had to say that she
was stopping her independent career and
going to work for tribeca
but
she had the opportunity
she met with someone who works with
billy crystal who was looking to work
with de niro on
what turned out to be analyzed this
eventually after i failed them
but they were looking to work together
and may slipped them my script
and
they loved it and they said this this
would work very well
and so all of a sudden tribeca
had to pick me up as like oh i guess
we'll pick up his script to take
so all of a sudden from
being about to quit i was working with
big hollywood stars and my agent lisa
calamaro arranged a fabulous option and
first step deal and all of a sudden i
didn't have to work temp for a year
while i did rewrites on that project
which went
so fast downhill and
died completely and the
they wanted changes that i didn't know
how to make and i had worked for 10
years learning how to write what was in
my head and i had never learned about
the part of hollywood writing where
somebody says
change that that
wasn't even on my radar and this was a
long time ago this was in the late 1980s
it just never occurred to me that like
someone would say as they did
it was the story was about a divorcing
couple a couple who had gotten divorced
and remarried and um divorced again
and over political differences and then
the guy gets involved in
espionage and politics and things and so
their divorce the topic of their divorce
becomes the subject of the thriller
and so it was sort of a thriller
romantic comedy
and
the note was can you take out the
divorce
and and it was a completely legitimate
note in one way if you were a flexible
hollywood writer who understood how to
rethink things there are ways to do that
and i actually did that later on another
script where i took out what i
considered the center of the story
at the time i had never had that
question raised and i tried so hard i
was just like i got to do this this is
my big break and i'm blowing it
but i couldn't i wrote an entire script
i've actually
it's the only thing i've ever written
that i have never looked at since it's
30 years now
i wrote it i literally cried through
much of the writing like i was a basket
case because i was writing something
that i didn't know what the center was
because for me the center of this story
the reason that everyone was doing
something was because of this couple
trying to get back together
when you take that out all you've got is
a bunch of people chasing each other
in funny ways but still wasn't enough to
make a scene
um
i wrote a script i have no idea if it's
readable
but i got immediately fired uh the
script went on on the shelf and they
hired new writers um and for three years
they held on to it and
de niron crystal wisely moved on did
analyze this it was a good choice on
their part um
and at the end of that three years i got
my script back which was cool because i
had been well paid
to let them have it for three years
i had never seen any of the rewrites
that were done after i did it so
therefore i was i was allowed to take
everything i had done that was my
property the script i the draft i done
for them was their property because they
paid me for it but the option was over
and i
just started sending it out again and i
so many people loved it and got so close
to production so many times
um
but what it taught me was the thing that
i thought writing was about which is you
imagine stuff and you get it down as
good as you can and then they pay you
and they make it that's not how
the industry works the industry works
that you
do all that stuff and then you start to
collaborate with other people and if you
can't do that part if you can't learn
how to use those same creative skills
on demand
for things you may not think are great
then they'll find someone who can does
that sound depressing it's not meant to
it's meant to it's meant to say
learn
the mechanics of the business
so that you can do the job
that's that's the message i hope is
being sent there is that there is the
magic of creativity and then there's the
magic
of being skilled and knowing how to do
the job
no matter what gets thrown at you well i
think it's very important that you bring
up that story because so many ideas of
something sound great and then when you
learn what they actually are it's much
much different so that's just
fascinating so it was a year that you
had to rewrite that or that was a year
process it was a year of
actually
this is it's a funny story so i'll tell
it uh it's embarrassing um i got once i
took out the center of the story
i didn't know what the story would be
and i what i do is that when i don't
know what i'm gonna write i just riff i
think of everything i can i brainstorm
it could be this it could be that you
know we're on a submarine it could be
the submarines at the bottom of the sea
it could be at the submarine got moved
to dry land what you know everything i
can possibly think i try and get it down
on paper
there's no such thing as a bad idea
until you've figured out what you're
trying to accomplish with it anything's
possible
so i had this huge list of possibilities
of this story
and i didn't know which one they wanted
and i was writing for them
so
i made it into a board game i actually i
was working as an office temp still so i
had access to like a laminating machine
everything and i made a board and it was
like it was like the game of life where
you go along a path but this had like
multiple branching paths for each story
and and i tried to lay out all the
different story outlines as a board game
with like cards like if you pick this
you go in this tray it was the most
elaborate
creative stupid thing i've ever done and
i brought it to billy crystal
i got an appointment i flew to los
angeles i gave it to him
and i said
this is your story outline
i don't know which one you want and he
was really gracious about it and he was
he was great he was like you know well
now i have something to put on the wall
of my office
but now we actually have to write the
script after work and he gave me advice
and i worked on it and i did a draft and
it was all fine but
that was how little i understood
the job the job by the way is making
choices
the point is when i when you
lay out the 15 000 possible stories you
have to make a choice
everything is a choice every choice has
a price you have to learn to get
comfortable
with making choices over and over and
over again everything
in creative work
is
i'm going to choose this and not that if
i choose this that means that i can't
have a happy ending if i choose this it
means i can't talk about
communism versus
capitalism you know whatever it is that
you want to do it's a choice
and when you make that choice
certain things fall away but other
things become stronger that's the
creative process and everyone gets very
afraid of that what if i make the wrong
choice
the coolest thing is whatever a writer
is to get comfortable with you know what
it's a choice i'm gonna make it i make
it judging i know that the producers
want this well no more choice that's
what i'm doing if you don't know for
sure
you change you take the choice and you
follow that path
you're gambling maybe it'll work maybe
it won't but it's better to make the
choice and be creative and try and find
your solutions than to try and do both
that's the one thing you can't do
got to make a choice and you have to
live with the price
when they asked you to take out which
what was the center of the story which
is the couple getting divorced and
getting back together
did they didn't tell you what to replace
it with
they didn't know when people give you
notes they don't know how to fix it they
they just like
you know that seems seems a little wrong
or sometimes they'll know how to fix it
but it's
not what you thought would be like you
may have a better one
it doesn't matter what matters is that
everyone is going to see things
differently and
most notes are
this isn't working
not do this
if they were to do this then it's like
i'll do that
most notes are that's not making sense
or that's too slow or that's too fast
but how you actually solve it that's
your task
and so for you that was so new it never
occurred to me
it was you know people didn't know that
much about screenwriting in the late 80s
early 90s like it wasn't as much of a
thing people didn't do it as much as
they do now now everybody writes scripts
and frankly everyone should because now
everyone can make them
but at the time the experience of being
a professional writer was not very well
known there were only a handful of books
and in fact the first time i came to la
um i was in my agent had come out and
she had set me up with meetings and
everyone said to me
your work is good you could work here if
you moved here um
but you would be have to get used to
writing things that didn't get made
because at the time that was how
development worked they would develop 50
scripts and make one which meant 49
writers were writing a script that was
going to be put on a drawer never seen
again and they would be highly paid and
they would be well respected and maybe
one of them would get lucky at one of
your scripts would would hit but you
never knew some people had a full career
never getting anything made um and that
blew my mind i was like i'm not gonna
work a whole year on a script and not
have anyone see it
which of course that's
the business that's the job
but at the time i didn't know i had no
clue and it took me a while to process
that and to recognize that
as a day job goes pretty cool you learn
a lot on it and you get paid to do the
thing you love
but it may get put on the shelf you may
never see it again
when you came back to them with other
ideas which could be the center of the
story
did they not like it or that was the
board game all right this is
the process by which this happens
is that the people who are in charge
like if you're a star or a director and
you're supervising writers
you know that you're not a writer and so
you just try to guide them as some are
better than others um and it's it's the
writer's job to translate
the notes
that's part of being a professional
screenwriter is recognizing that people
are going to tell you stuff and you have
to figure out
what i believe is you have to figure out
how to turn it into scenes everything
about screenwriting is how to think in
scenes if you can figure out how to make
a scene
out of an idea or a desire or whatever
it is that somebody says
then you can be a professional writer
and um
so
very often the people in charge will say
like honestly you know i know what end
result i want but i don't know how to
get there that's your job
um so that was
a lot of the notes were like that and in
fact i said
i said here's the thing when it really
comes down to it there's a big there's a
binary choice there's a this or that you
know is it a this ending or that ending
and the note was well could it be both
what are you going to do so eventually i
just chose
i actually think this board game is kind
of cool but it was great i wish i don't
know if i have a copy of it i think i
gave him the only copy that's kind of a
neat idea i mean if someone had the time
to make the board game that that would
be yeah absolutely no i mean essentially
it's create your own story which is now
a completely legitimate creative
project you know you could you can you
know digitally you can make a story that
you could do that with i think it's
called a video game you know and um so i
just was decades ahead of my there you
go
i should have been designing games
do you think things have changed in
hollywood in the past five years
everything has changed uh in the past
five years the
i i personally believe that the changes
happening right now in the entertainment
industry are the biggest
since the invention of film back in
1905. um
even
television coming of television the
coming of of home media had did not
disrupt the the system as much as the
events of the digital technology changes
um
if you don't mind me getting into that
one reason is because
when film began
they built up a bunch of companies in
the 1920s in the silent era and those
became the studios and the studios sort
of ran the world
for the next
decades there were only a small set of
studios and they all
essentially worked in the same field and
they all owned the same theaters
that system
eventually incorporated television at
first they thought television would be a
threat but then they simply
moved television into their system the
studios ran so many things in television
when the digital revolution happened
new companies came in and instead of
buying a studio and saying keep doing
what you're doing they built their own
studios based in entirely different
philosophies
and they also built their own
distribution companies because you have
to remember the entire movie industry
was is a distribution industry the movie
studios were stu were filmed
distributors they made movies in order
to have something to distribute and um
the most important thing to them was
distribution because that's where the
people pay money to get the product
distribution is where the money is and
with streaming services they simply
opened up a whole new
avenue of distribution that cut the
studios out of the business they took
the business away from the studios and
as a result
everything changed the the people
running it the philosophies by which
they ran it everything has changed and
it's broken up because
the ability to choose what you're
watching the ability to meter how things
are watched all of these things are
changing what gets made
as a result
everything is sort of broken up into
each company has its own plans its own
philosophy and they are buying and
producing according to what they want to
do they are not doing it according to
some unified industry philosophy of this
is what's a hit
furthermore a lot of the technology
companies their principle is if somebody
else is already doing something we have
to do something very different
that it was never like paramount was
like oh you know they're doing this kind
of movie so we'll never do that kind of
movie that's not how that worked they
all did the same kind of movie and so
you could just say
i'm going to make a western because
everybody's making westerns
now
every company every streaming service
they're constantly changing what they
want
so you can't
plan
on ah i can write this and it will be
sold
that doesn't happen it has to be a
magical combination of you being good at
your writing and the company having the
desire to make that thing and the only
way that you can
make that happen is doing your part of
it you do the good work and you put it
out there there's a lot of places out
there hopefully one of them will pick it
up
that's all you can do in the face of
this new system which is no longer
unified around one set of
objectives
do you think people realize that the
rules that they've been living by are no
longer there no
i think um
i i know that's this copyright but you
know wiley coyote when he runs off a
cliff and there's a section there where
he's running in thin air with his legs
spinning but he's still going straight
ahead and as far as he's concerned he's
on solid ground
i believe that is where we are
which is
most of the people who are working in
the industry and most of the people who
are teaching about the industry are
operating from pre-digital philosophies
they're like this is what a story is
this is how a thing gets sold
and in fact we're all on thin air and
we're gonna drop
we may have a parachute we may get a
glider i'm not saying we're gonna smash
i'm just saying the ground has shifted
under our feet and so the concept of
three acts the concept that a movie is
uh the the story unit these have all
changed a story a story can be in 78
parts a story can be in six half hours
in each of those it's gonna have a
different kind of structure how can you
possibly talk about a universal
structure or a a mythic
paradigm that's going to fit all of
those i believe the only thing that fits
all of those
is an understanding of the basic tools
of writing a narrative for people to
film which means understanding that
you've got characters who are trying to
accomplish something
and they they operate in scenes the one
thing i think is true still of all
uh filmed entertainment is that it works
in scenes and
you're going to need to understand how
scenes work every character who enters a
scene
has a desire to accomplish something
they are in that scene for their own
reason
and
if you uh learn how to write those
scenes you learn how to write a
character's objective and at the end of
that scene something has changed or
frustrated them and so they move into
the next scene with that next objective
and when you outline that whole thing
into six half hours or 72 hours or an
hour and a half whatever it is that
basic principle of of drama of
storytelling is is what you should get
good at
how do you define story and how do you
teach it to clients and students
i think the basic
idea of a story is going to be that you
are following a character or characters
it is entirely possible to tell the
story of multiple characters you don't
only have to tell one person's story
it's nice you can do it but it's also
possible to tell a story with 11 main
characters it takes a lot of work you
have to follow each main character
and follow their story all the way
through the narrative but
in fact i believe any story is really
about how a character trying to
accomplish something runs into other
people who either help or harm their
intention it's sort of like
isaac newton's theory of
the billiard balls that they they once
they get set in motion they will roll in
that same direction because they're
being pushed by a physical force and i
think a character is also doing that
they're they're trying to get somewhere
and they're rolling in a certain
direction until either they hit
something or something comes along and
knocks into them and then that changes
their direction but they're still trying
to get to that one place
the physics kind of falls apart there
because billiard balls aren't trying to
get anywhere but the idea that things
are moving until they run into something
else which is also moving
is sort of how characters work
every character
thinks they're the main character if you
have your hero walk into a hotel and try
and get a hotel room that hotel clerk
they think they're the center of the
movie because they're the center of
their story and this person coming up to
them
is either getting in their way or
they're trying to charm them or whatever
it is that they're doing they're trying
to do something and that interchange is
the basic building blocks of story
that's what you call dramatic action
someone trying to accomplish something
which mostly involves interacting with
other people sometimes the action can be
i have to take this suitcase and put it
on a train whatever but there'll still
be i have to i have a thing i'm trying
to accomplish and that's what story is i
have a thing i am trying to accomplish i
am a character and i need to get this
thing and it will be a more interesting
story if there's something in the way
if
i am a character i'm trying to put a
suitcase on a train and i go and i put
it on the train and nothing happens it's
a very short boring story if they're
carrying a suitcase and another person
comes and they steal the suitcase
it's more of an interesting story and
it's a more interesting story if that
person's got something important in the
suitcase if it's just a suitcase they
could say oh somebody stole it oh well
i'll go get another one not that strong
a story
um
every story is about a character trying
to accomplish something and having an
obstacle and what they do what action
they take in the face of the obstacles
is your
story the obstacles don't have to be
external the obstacle can be i'm really
afraid of the train station i need to
get this suitcase to my uncle and he's
going to be at the other end of the
train so i've got to get this
suitcase onto the train but i'm
terrified of loud noises
that's a story the only obstacle is in
there but it's real
so
every character is facing obstacles the
obstacles don't have to be physical they
don't have to be another character they
just have to be something that's getting
in the way of them trying to accomplish
something that's important to them
can you explain how questions and
choices
inform the writing process
writing is a process of questions that
like if i could there's a couple of
things that i wish i could like get
tattooed on the inside of people's
eyelids that they knew
think in scenes
and writing is a process of questions
it's not a thing you have to fill out
it's not a form that you have to fit
into
writing is a question is always a
process of
having something
it could be just i want to write a
western or i want to talk about
how
love hurts or i want to talk about how
love saved my life whatever it is that
you start with then you start to ask
questions
how am i going to
tell this story am i going to tell it
through a character who gets it or
doesn't get it everything is going to be
a choice every question that you ask if
you write down that question
how am i going to tell this story who is
the main character everything is a
question and those questions are who is
it about
what do they want
why can't they get it
what do they do about that
and how does it end i think i skipped
one but
oh why doesn't that work right
who's it about what do they want
why can't they get it what do they do
about that why doesn't that work how
does it end i did a whole video on this
called the six essential questions so i
explained it better there but
those six questions basically
will help you write anything they'll
help you write a movie they'll help you
write a video game they'll help you
write a series because that's the
essential thing that you get
of
how am i going to turn whatever feeling
or idea i have into a story is a person
who is trying to do something to get
something
and there's something in the way
and then eventually something will end
it either the end will be i don't get it
or i do get it and whatever they do that
they had never tried before is how it
ends
because if they had tried it before it
would end before
so
who's it about what do they want what do
they do
why doesn't that work what do they
finally do what is the end
that's storytelling and it can work for
three acts or 27 acts or one act it
always works it's it's my go-to set of
questions
and then just keep asking questions who
is it about it's about a plumber
where is he from just ask who what why
where and just keep asking why
why is he afraid of heights why you know
why does he love this particular person
every time you ask a question and you
get a specific answer you're moving
closer to writing a scene
what's the easiest way for someone to
figure out an enjoyable writing process
for themselves
the first
important thing about your process is
recognizing that it's yours that there
is not a right or wrong way
some people write at night some people
write in the day some people write in
short bursts some people write in long
extended verses it's there's no
particular better or worse process the
important thing about a process is it's
something that you can do
relatively easily
for whatever reason it works for you and
that means you have to spend time paying
attention to yourself trying different
things and seeing which ones work and
which ones don't work and being really
honest about that i personally
keep doing that sorry
i personally um i
turned out to write very well in short
bursts
i thought i should
do more because when i'm writing in a
short burst it's like holy crap if i
could keep doing this for eight hours
i'd be a miracle
but i can't
and i would sit there and i would grind
after the burst was running down i would
grind and not only would that be
unproductive and begin to be
disheartening but i would start to undo
my good work because when you start to
grind in a bad way
you start to doubt you start to feel bad
and you say well i must be feeling bad
because this work is bad which is not
necessarily the case it could be that
your process is bad
and so what i would do is i would write
something really good and then i would
grind until i was
unhappy and then i would say oh that
sucks and then i would
write something over it and destroy my
own good work and it took me a long time
to pay attention to the fact that i do
really well in short bursts
and if i stop when i feel myself
starting to lose it
and
take a break take a walk do exercises
whatever i can then come back and do
another short burst getting myself to
sit down again is rough but that's the
thing i had to teach myself by paying
attention to what worked
i've gotten much more productive since i
learned my process it's not for everyone
everyone will have a process that's
dependent on their own inner mechanisms
and on their own reality
some people only have free time
on weekends some people only get a
little bit of free time you know in the
evenings and so they have to find a way
to work at the time that they are
allowed by their life
you have to pay attention to reality and
pay attention to your own inner working
and the best way to
find out
is to do it and see how it goes
it's always better to try and do some
work
and see how it goes you'll never get to
the place where you absolutely know that
you can write and then you start writing
it's always a question of let me try
this see what comes out
that's the best test of a process
and working these temp jobs
for many other reasons aside from income
and people the study of people
helped you realize that was your
preferred story forced me because i'm
stubborn and i would just keep doing the
wrong thing over and over again until uh
circumstances forced me to work in short
bursts and then i was like wow that
actually is better
trying to be open to your process trying
to
pay attention to what actually makes the
work good what feels good feeling good
is underrated like the fact that you
know you have to learn to write when you
don't feel good
for me
having a process that i can say i always
i have
five basic documents that i open like an
outline a place where i write notes
and the the text itself and the sort of
overview i'm gonna be doing a video on
this actually soon but that's my
personal setup everyone has their own
but but what you need to do is find a
thing that so you always when you open
that notebook you're not thinking
about anything except the contents of
the work you know ah this is the outline
the outline is going to be broken into
scenes and the scene lines are going to
look like this and i don't have to think
about that i have to think about what's
in the scene
that's the best way to find a process is
to get something that works for you
some people will do it on their phone
some people will do it i would advise
doing it in some way that it's written
down in some form digitally on paper on
note cards it doesn't matter what
matters is that you get it out of your
head and into the world in some way that
you can set it aside and come back to it
set it aside come back to it because
with almost anything you're going to
have to you can't do it all at once
when did you have that aha moment that
i don't have writer's block and my
anxiety was although it was real
it was just that wasn't my style of
writing to to sit at my desk at my
parents basement or wherever
and have the perfect music and iced tea
that that actually wasn't working for me
it was
it was unfortunately not an aha moment
it was an aha a couple of years
and i think i think that that's a that's
actually sort of a misleading thing that
that our culture has developed from
movies um is that that there's a
decisive moment and after it you are
always changed in stories that is a very
important thing you need decisive
moments when people are changed but in
truth it's more like a series and i have
a couple seasons
where i get a little bit of it then i
fall back into my old ways and then i
have some reward or i think of something
new and it it's a process
in which
you try to do two steps forward one step
back instead of the other way around
because you're trying to head forward
you do a little forward you fall back
you go a little forward
and and the main
way it always is
the doing of it just
throw something on the paper
even if it's just and i have done this
i've ever seen what i say this is the
scene where he comes home and is you
know miserable
and i just took it out of the outline
and i wrote it into the script because
the next time i look at it
i i now am familiar with this process
and i say okay
i created a scene the scene is a
description this is where he comes home
and it's miserable now i have to think
okay
how do we see that he's miserable ask a
question
he sees we see he's miserable because he
takes his
little dinner out of the refrigerator
and throws it on the wall you know
each thing that you get when you ask a
question
to me it's always a process of questions
and a process of writing down the answer
now i have a scene where a guy comes in
opens his fridge throws his dinner
against the wall okay we know he's
miserable
now i can add a couple of lines move on
to the next scene
everything that you can do to put a
little something down to create a bit of
something for your creativity to hang on
to
that's
for me the essence of the writing
process
so if this were a movie
then it would show glenn as a temp
and you know all right charlie have a
good weekend and then you had like a
half hour and then the music played and
you realize
wow this is it and i'm i hear i am
writing it and and you're saying i
actually think what we would do in that
case is we would show that we would cut
to the see the imaginary scene we would
play it out and and so we would get to
catch the the thrill of the creation by
seeing the created magic of this
character in the scene oh so yeah sorry
i'm writing that no i love it i love it
so then so glenn is the as i'm writing
the writing then we you know cut to or
dissolve to by the way that's a little
thing most of the time hey don't write
cut to william goldman started it it's a
delightful thing in his scripts
obviously they're going to cut too how
else are they going to get there you're
wasting page space
don't say cut to and most of the time
don't say dissolve to or fade out or
anything else because that's their
decision they'll unless it's really
important that you dissolve
just
write the next scene and they'll figure
out how to get there
anyway
yeah get to the
glenn's writing and then show that scene
where the character is running to the
phone booth in the rain and it's a great
scene and people will get so excited by
my creativity as a character that
they'll want to know what happens next
you say the writing process is about
tools and skills not theory but let's
let's go with theory for one moment so
what theories are stopping a writer
before they even start
that's actually a really good question
because um
i believe that the theories
are tools i believe that the the all the
rules i'm not saying there are no rules
there are plenty of rules there are a
lot of rules what they are not is a
single set of rules that always works
and so what you need to do is know every
possible theory you can cram into your
head you should watch
all sorts of different types of stories
you should watch outside in genres
outside of the ones you like you should
specifically try to watch things that
are
things you don't think you'd be
interested in and you should definitely
try to
read those screenwriting books or or
listen to screenwriting teachers who are
teaching very very different ideas
because there are so many out there now
and the answer is each one of them will
have very valuable parts
very valuable
tools that you can use and the only
thing that you need to have is a really
big toolbox as big as you can get with
every possible theory so that when
you're approaching your work which is
really what it's always going to be
about you can say i have seen a story
like this or i have seen a story like
this but this other story had a
different form for it or
this person said i should always have my
transitions in the middle of the story
or this one said i should always have a
conflict at the end of the story there's
so many theories
none of them is wrong they're all right
they're all there to be used in
different circumstances depending on
what you're trying to accomplish
so the more that you can learn
all the different theories and all the
different paradigms and and story
archetypes
that's all good but nothing will help
until you actually sit down and say i am
making the choice to write this
particular story and this story needs
this
set of rules maybe another story needs
another set maybe i need to pick one
rule from this one and one rule from
that one maybe my you know somebody says
you know save the cat
i happen to believe that there are
certain parts of save the cat the book
very valuable other parts i can't make
head or tail of and i don't think that
you should not read it i think you
should read it and take the pieces that
you need i'm not sure you should always
save the cat
but it's good to know that saving the
cat is a thing you can do
and
i believe that that goes for every
screenwriting theory out there and the
best thing that you can do is know all
of them so that you can say hmm in this
one is this type of character best
revealed by saving a cat or is this one
somebody who's gonna walk away and leave
the cat there and now we know a
different thing about them how do we
still like them
so
really the most important thing is to
take whatever these rules are
and
apply them to your particular goals
because that's the thing
not every story has the same goals some
are trying to amuse you some are trying
to scare you some are trying to make you
think they're going to have very
different ways of approaching
storytelling
the important thing is that you have as
many tools as you can as many skills you
know how to make something funny if you
need to or how to make somebody like a
character
by the way my theory on liking a
character is the way that we like a
character is that we know what they want
i believe we can really get with a
character who wants something horrible
they're not saving any cats they're
murderers or they're trying to take over
the world and we can still really care
about them because we are understand
that they want this thing for their
reason and very often
that's something that we can care about
even though we don't honestly want them
to kill all those people
but
we get engaged in the story and we
follow the characters because we know
what they want
my theory
so if we don't know what they what they
want then somehow
do we not trust the character
i personally think we just don't think
of them as a character
i think if you if you start to pay
attention to how you watch characters i
think you'll find out that you're always
thinking what do they want what are they
trying to do there'll be some form of
that you don't just want to watch
someone say oh they have nice clothes i
mean you'll watch that for a few minutes
but after a while
that person in the cool outfit had
better be trying to do something and
people don't try to do something if they
don't want something
because it takes effort to do stuff and
we only do that when we have something
we want
if we had that toolbox let's let's say
we put aside the save the cat tool
what's one of the most overused whether
it's good or bad tool
one or two from this toolbox um
we're we're gonna pull it out and make
room for other stuff yeah um
i think the three-act structure
it's tricky there are there is a
a world where
there's units of entertainment
which you watch in one dose
call them features now doesn't matter it
could be a short but but there's a type
of story that you watch in one dose and
that does have a three-act structure in
the sense that it has a beginning middle
and end but the whole set of rules about
turning points happening at a certain
point in a three-act structure
is simply an overused tool uh it came
about because movies were in movie
theaters and that was about as long as a
person could sit in a movie theater and
also movie theaters wanted to sell a
certain number of tickets so they wanted
movies to be of a certain length a lot
of this comes down to business and
honestly we shouldn't be making our
artistic decisions based on the fact
that
movie theaters wanted to turn over the
seats every 90 minutes
um now we have some stories that are
not three acts we have some stories that
are 30 acts we have some stories that
are one act
every story though will have
a beginning middle and end
so in a way the three act structure will
apply even an episode of a larger thing
has a beginning middle and end
i think that's where the three act thing
came from because truthfully even in
theater they didn't always have three
acts a lot of plays before the
19th the 20th century had four acts or
five acts so three act save the cat
possibly doesn't mean they're bad or
wrong but it's just they're over they
they're used a lot
i'm saying that you need to choose your
form
you need to say
i am going to
watch a thousand stories and i'm going
to break some down i strongly suggest
that if there's something you like watch
it like five times watch it until you're
not enjoying it anymore so you can start
to watch it mechanically and say how do
they do this and when you do that
stop
like pause and write an outline of the
thing you're watching that you like and
learn how it's structured and then do
that with a bunch of other things
because you'll find out there's nothing
consistent the rules are all over the
place and furthermore
a lot of these rules are like well you
have your inciting incident or your you
know beginning twist or whatever they
everybody has names for them
none of that really matters
because then you get into
an activity which is an academic
activity of
find the part i'm going to name the
inciting incident what really matters is
how the audience feels as they're
following the story the audience is not
looking for an inciting incident they're
not looking for a
second act reversal they don't care they
care about the characters and if you
break down the things you love and
reverse engineer them and outline them
you'll begin to get a sense of how they
do it how many beats does it take before
you are worn out of this thing how long
does it go before there's a twist or a
turn
the only way you can really become
skilled is by
breaking down the work and doing it
yourself
you know you can study how to build a
car until the end of time but you need
to actually put together a car and make
it run
and you probably have to do that a bunch
of times before you can make a really
great car
how is being an artist very different
from being the audience
that is one of the hardest things to get
used to because we all begin as an
audience there i don't think there's an
artist in the world who didn't start by
being a fan
we all want to do these things because
we liked seeing them absorbing them
we were the best consumers
and
the truth is
the artist never experiences their own
work the way an audience will because
they first you know what's going to
happen you can't actually experience it
you have to reverse engineer that whole
experience just like if you were if
you're building a roller coaster
you can't be riding the roller coaster
at the same time you have to actually
say i need a support here and i need a
dip here and you're being very
mechanical and frankly artificial about
it because you're saying i want them to
get a throw when they go over that hoop
hump
and
and in order to do that i'm going to
have to have this amount of force up
here and then it's going to have to have
a
tailing out at that point and it's going
to become very mechanical in order to
give somebody else the pleasure of
riding that roller coaster
that's what you need to do as an artist
is to say
i love the experience of going over that
hump and then zooming down
and for some reason i don't crash at the
bottom that's because someone knew how
to get out of the free fall that i'm
going through
the artist has to stop and learn the
mechanics
how you support the track that's going
to do that how you make the story twist
and turn and provoke those experiences
that you yourself will never have
and
when you're actually doing it you get
this weird kind of duality because as
you're creating you usually have like a
little tiny bit of an audience's
experience you'll be like
i'm actually enjoying the line i just
thought of as an audience did you'll
have that for a fraction of a second
while you're doing it
and then after that you have to figure
out the mechanics to make that scene
work
so you're constantly going back and
forth sort of saying i
want to be an audience now and now in
order to get that audience i got to go
back and become the mechanic and you're
constantly cycling through them you can
never really give up being an audience
but you have to also become
the person building the ride
the other thing about artists and
audiences
is that
from the finished product you can never
tell how it got made
one of the things i think artists really
should do is try to read or hear
podcasts or books about how things you
love got made because you'll always be
amazed at how the people who set out to
do it did not know that the final result
was going to be what we now think of as
inevitable and the the stories are
actually i just read one about midnight
cowboy and and when they brought the
book midnight cowboy john schlesinger
the director and the producer brought
the book to mgm the studio and they said
we want to do this
very dark story about this wannabe
hustler going to times square and mgm
said
we think this could be an elvis presley
vehicle and we're going to put in some
songs and we'll take out that dark stuff
so
you know
on a bad day mgm could have taken it
over and it could have been elvis
presley in midnight cowboy which would
have been something to see
but the point is when we watch midnight
cowboy it never occurs to us
how
many different things had to go right or
had to be learned to make that happen
and having worked
behind the scenes having created things
i can tell you that there are things
that i did not know going in somebody
brought it to me sometimes whole story
ideas were not my idea in fact
the script i'm best known for fracture
wasn't my original script someone else
had written a very very good script the
studio wanted to make changes someone
else was hired after that then i was
brought in so many of the plot twists i
didn't come up with i did a lot of the
writing that made those plot twists work
in that form that it did end up in but
when you watch that movie you come to me
and say how did you think of that plot
twist the answer is i read it in
somebody else's script and i used it
because that's the job
so the answer is
you can't just look at stuff you love
and go ooh i know how they did that
you'll never know how they did that and
you'll never know how your work is going
to come out you just don't you have to
get used to the experience of trying to
get something done
doing the best you can
and seeing how it plays
had talked about something in the
artistic process
abstract to concrete to abstract
yes what is that um
that's sort of a follow-up of the artist
um
artist audience issue which is
you nothing will ever come out like it
feels to you
that is part of the art i don't i don't
think there's any artist who hasn't
gotten hopefully used to it because it's
part of learning how to do it
um one of the things that brought this
to me was i was once looking at a
picasso drawing and late picasa drawings
especially are just like they're like
scribbles you know it's it looks sort of
like a bull but
how did he know to make the line go like
how did he know to do that because it's
just a scribble but it's a bull
and i suddenly realized he didn't know
he knew that whatever came out would be
interesting he trusted that and that's
what every artist has to learn that you
don't know exactly how it's going to
come out you can outline i outline
incredibly thoroughly and i
think i know what's going to happen but
the truth is that there's going to be a
process after that the creative process
good word for it you're creating
something out of nothing and when that
happens it's going to be something that
you're going to discover as you do it
and then you need to shape it and rework
it and do all the other things that
artists have to do but
the thing in your head there's this
feeling or this idea or this line and
then you put it on the page and then
somebody else performs it and then
someone else sees it and in all of those
steps it's not what you thought it was
going to be and the best thing an artist
can do is get really comfortable
in a sense getting comfortable with a
failure you're going to fail to get your
exact feeling and thought out to someone
else
that's that's life it will never ever
happen that someone gets exactly what
you thought it was but what will happen
is you'll get used to doing that
scribble and someone will go oh cool
ball
and that's art that's the magic of it is
that you get used to bringing something
abstract into a concrete form and
someone else gets an abstract experience
out of it that's
that's something that only art does it's
beautiful
so get used to
sounds like just experimenting and and
trusting that i may not know where it's
going but this kind of feels right and
knowing that that same thing you could
see it could be changed drastically and
you have to be collaborative and okay
with that
get used to the process get used to the
experience of doing the thing over and
over if you're playing tennis you get
used to hitting the ball and you hit it
over and over and then eventually you'll
get to where you can control it more but
still there's going to be a lot of other
elements and what only thing that you
can get used to is the process of making
the swing likewise the process of
thinking of something writing it in a
concrete form editing it
shaping it rewriting it giving it to
other people that process that's what
you have to practice that's what you
have to get to enjoy and feel comfort in
and the more that you do it the more
that you'll get lucky and things will
work out and you'll be like oh i think
this line is funny and then you write it
down and someone reads it and they they
laugh
that gives you so much
power for the next time you do it
because sometimes it's going to work and
sometimes it's going to not work but
the more you do it
the more it will work
two kinds of writing
creating and shaping there are two kinds
of writing
and
every piece of writing uses both kinds
it's not like somebody only does
creating and somebody only does the
shaping every writer has to get used to
sort of a
over and over again process
um
creating
what i call creating and it's just the
the stuff that comes out what some
people call the vomit draft or
the um the experience of just
trying to imagine stuff and write down
what you think trying to put yourself in
a scene or think what would they say
next and write it down
you're accessing something that truly
humanity has no idea what it is or where
it comes from i don't know if it's
something that other creatures have but
people have this weird ability to make
stuff up uh it's essentially dreaming um
you
think of a story or a character or a
moment or a scene or a line and you
don't you can't really say where it
comes from uh
and this is every artist in history has
experience has described the same
experience of
i was trying to write this thing and
this line just came to me this scene
this twist whatever it is it just comes
to you
and the more that you can get used to
the
um
need to let it happen however it happens
to create without any judgment at all
without any criticism without any fear
saying anything that comes out of me at
this moment is fine
and to be able to sustain that and do
that for a bit of time and get something
down and to get used to the experience
of
making that written down
feeling free with the words even if
they're bad even if if you're bad at
typing they're going to be misspelled
doesn't matter what matters is that they
you grab them from that mysterious place
and you get them on the paper that's
creating but then
almost always it's going to need some
shaping some editing some rethinking
writing rewriting and that second
shaping part is where you say
clean up all the typos
break that long sentence into two short
ones make those two short ones into one
long one
that word there that's really vague what
do i mean when i say
baffled
baffle is actually pretty specific but
you know what i mean
that do you start to
think the way someone who's not you
would read it and whether they would get
the experience you're trying to give
them and then you start to be mechanical
about it there's tricks you can use
putting the punch line at the end
putting the set up at the beginning
finding funny sounding words for funny
lines there's all these tricks of the
trade that goes in the shaping part
when you're shaping you're spending a
lot of time being critical
and trying to when you're critical what
you're trying to do is i like to think
of critical as making the best of not
saying bad i'm not critical of it i am
wow there's a funny bit in that but this
is getting in the way so critically i'm
going to get rid of the stuff that's in
the way of the good i like the good
what's important about being critical is
that you're doing it to improve what it
is trying to be
not make it into something else
and certainly not just slam it down
the editing part of you the rewriting
part of you is the second part of the
process usually
it goes back and forth several times
sometimes you get weirdly creative while
you're editing a new line comes to you
and then you so you're sort of doing a
micro switch editing editing oh new line
creative oh back to editing
and that process goes over and over
most writers i know they tend to set
aside a separate mood you know
i know i'm going to have to do seven
days of creating creating craving i'm
never gonna look back at what i wrote
and i'm just gonna every day set aside
an hour
throw it down and then
go you know make myself a nice lunch
then for another seven days i'm going to
look at what i wrote
take a big deep breath start to break it
down start to do the work
stretch a little go back to it
and that process over and over will make
for
great writing
do you think too many writers are
focused on positive feedback instead of
writing something that can actually be
made
that's interesting um actually i do
think that
we have developed a script
reading
industry within the industry
and that has sort of become a kind of i
don't know what the term is for like if
you've got a river and it suddenly gets
like a little backwater and things get
stuck in there instead of going with the
flow but that's there is that um
people who are writing scripts
are unfortunately mostly writing them to
be judged by people whose jobs is to
read them that could be professional
script readers and critics it can also
be anyone who is an executive or a
producer their job is to read a script
and try and figure out if that script is
going to be producible but still they're
they're working on the script many many
people who are in those fields don't
know anything about production they
don't know anything about making a movie
and in fact
when i say movie i mean movie or show or
filmed entertainment of any kind
the most important thing for a
screenwriter because it's a particular
kind of writer is that you are writing
for production
there is no value to your writing until
it is produced someone may pay you money
which is value in the sense that they
think it's going to get produced but
truthfully the value is if that script
can be acted and directed and edited and
released
and there's different qualities which
are valuable to the people doing the
acting directing editing than the
readers
and you need to be able to please both
because you can't get to the production
people
without going through the readers
so i would say you need to learn all the
advice about how to please a reader and
what they're looking for and what they
the rules they have and everybody tells
you different rules but know as many
rules as you can
but still it's very important to
understand what happens when a script
gets made
if you can
make it yourself
write a script for the purpose of making
it yourself just so that you learn what
happens when an actor has to say the
lines one of the things that happens is
you'll learn most of the lines that you
wrote were probably information in other
words you were thinking i need the
audience to know this thing so i'll
write a line where somebody says it in
some way
but what the actor and the director and
the editor need is for the character to
need to say something
totally different the character has to
need to say the information if they
don't need to say it it's not going to
work for the actor and the director the
only way that you can learn that
is by having actors and directors work
with your script if you are a diy type
of person
try it find a way to you know at this
point you can do it on your phone you
can get a bunch of actors from the
nearby community theater or college
write something that's appropriate to
their ability of talent and
try it out
it's going to take you some time it's
going to be some heartache there's going
to be some arguments but you will learn
how
your script is transformed by the
production process what works and
doesn't work
and that is incredibly valuable
to everyone who eventually will make the
movie and if you can learn that stuff
by and you can pretty much only learn it
by doing it
then you will be a
screenwriter who's making something not
just to get approval but to actually get
made and be good
so by running these lines by these
actors and filming it with your phone
you're finding out what's filler in the
dialogue and what is
an actor or character
wanting something portraying that to
another character who also wants
something what it really will come down
to is you'll learn what dramatic action
is because dialogue is action when
somebody speaks actually in real life
too you're trying to do something like
when you go to a counter and say may i
have a pack of cigarettes well don't say
that say say may i have a
club soda and a lottery
ticket yeah
when you say that it's because you're
trying to accomplish something when you
say to someone
i love you or i don't love you anymore
it's because you're trying to accomplish
something you're trying to make
something happen or get something you're
trying to change your relationship with
them you're trying to get something some
of them to do something
all dialogue should be action that's
what an actor needs to play and that's
what a director needs to direct
is that almost every writer you'll meet
especially the ones who have not been in
production will think in terms of
information this dialogue is conveying
this information and they can make it
sound nice but if it's not actually
action if the character is not trying to
change something in that moment
it's not going to play
by the way the other thing i wanted to
say was
i'm a fan of diy and i think that we
should
demystify it the point of diy filmmaking
is mostly not to get your big break and
to have it sell for a billion dollars
it's to get experience it's the it's the
same thing that the
the 10 000 hours you know uh malcolm
gladwell in um
uh oh gosh i can't remember the name of
the book now malcolm gladwell uh
publicized this phrase um outliers is
malcolm gladwell's outliers
ten thousand hours is what it takes to
be a real mastery of any particular
thing you're doing
it took me like thirty thousand because
i'm really stubborn and slow but um
that
process for a screenwriter
has to include the production and
what happened was the the indie industry
blew up in the the 80s and 90s over
somebody makes a 3 000 movie and it
sells a billion dollars and and they're
great for the rest of their career
um and so everyone started making movies
for that aim
for every one of those that was huge
there were
thousands that lost all their money and
the important thing to know about diy is
you're going to lose all your money the
you might as well
grab a lottery ticket to try and make
money off of indie filmmaking but that's
not the point the point is to do the
work and get it to an audience to get in
production and if you don't feel like
diying yourself there are people who are
wanting to diy who can't write and they
will love you if you just want to write
and give it to them
so
the important thing about that is the
same thing that the ten thousand hours
taught the beatles when they went to
hamburg and they had to play
god knows eight hour sets every day for
weeks and weeks on end supposedly that's
when they got good
the work they were doing was not
necessarily their best work but they
were
producing their work and putting in
front of an audience and doing it again
the next day
that's the important thing that
screenwriters are not given the
opportunity to do you're not going to be
given that opportunity so you should
take it yourself
do it a nice safe way like i said if
you're a writer and you don't feel like
producing
find people out there they want good
scripts
when you were attempt for those 12 years
was there one story that you really
clung to
of your own of your own writing that you
thought
this is going to be it or were you
constantly working on new things well i
did have this one script that kept on
getting passed around and people liked
for those 10 years and eventually it did
sell so that that for those who out
there yeah 10 years it can still sell
and frankly after that 10 years 10 years
after that it was still being shown and
people were showing interest in it so
that's one of the important things that
you should remember when you write
something and you're thinking this will
be my break it might be your break in
the sense that people recognize your
talent through it and they never make
that but it becomes quote a show script
that's a perfectly valuable thing i got
a lot of show scripts i thought they
were going to be big hits i thought they
were going to make me a fortune but they
were just something that somebody read
and said wow you're a good writer why
don't you write this thing that i think
will make money
that's still a valid reason to write a
script and the script still exists
you know somebody doesn't buy it it's
not like it gets burned somebody else
later on might like it
i'm wondering if we can critique some
dialogue of a scene i've written
the scene is set in modern times and it
takes place in a hr human resources
department where our protagonist is maya
she's a single mom in her mid-30s
she works as an administrative assistant
she's not one for i guess what you would
call water cooler gossip she's kind of
you know head down works hard
some of the other employees don't like
her but she she kind of tunes it out the
other person in the scene is tommy and
he's a young hr professional in his
mid-20s he landed the job out of college
and he's been promoted as he's a
diligent worker and committed to seeing
the company run smoothly
so tommy has sent maya an interoffice
email and asked her to be at his office
he does not say why in the email and so
the scene takes place where maya is
knocking on the office door of tommy's
which is a jar he's at his computer so
maya says hi tommy and she knocks
hey tommy sound effect it's cool yeah
sorry yeah that's fine
and there's uh
tommy typing i don't actually have the
typing sound um oh hey maya
thanks for stopping by have a seat
please maya sits down in the office
chair facing tommy's desk her body
language is a bit tense
tommy speaks
so and he quickly gets up from his chair
and shuts the office door
okay
maya thanks again for being here listen
tommy pauses to reflect
miley leans in
everything good
there's a little bit of an inflection in
her voice which indicates worry
tommy clears his throat and breathes in
maya as you know our company policy
states that all employees electronic
communications are monitored from time
to time so that human resources can be
certain that said employees are in
accordance with company rules and
regulations
my response
okay
tommy from october 25th maya to january
25th our it department noted that within
this span of time you had spent an
excessive amount of time on
non-work-related websites
during your agreed upon hours of
employment with us using a company
computer which is located at your desk
and maya interrupts tommy wait what
what are you talking about
tommy raises his voice slightly louder
as you may remember maya from the
company handbook that was given to you
on your first day of employment with us
which you signed all computer time
within an employee's work hours should
be strictly work related
it was noted and he pulls out his little
handy-dandy pen clicking it
it was noted that you visited the
following websites on these dates and he
turns around a piece of paper that's
printed and denotes with his pen each
incident
maya looks at the paper in disbelief
and she sees on the paper a time stamp a
url of the alleged website the make
model and operating system of her work
computer scanning the paper and shaking
her head she kind of exclaims
i don't even have an account on the
social media site and i've never been to
this blog i don't know what this is
tommy exhales and pauses
therefore maya in violation of company
policy
we're really sorry but we're going to
have to let you go
maya responds
okay wait stop
i noticed the other day there was a
login page to my computer and the
username was someone else's
i don't go to these websites
i don't even go to these websites on my
off hours so what are you talking about
gets defensive tommy interrupting my
your check has been prepared we will pay
you through 5 p.m today
we will need your access card and the
key to your desk before giving you this
final check
are you able to provide these two items
for us today and so that's the dialogue
um
you want me to work yeah please okay
let's do that okay um cool by the way
fun yeah um
the first thing i'd say is we don't have
to worry about the dialogue yet okay the
first thing you have to ask is what is
the scene about
because
the person is doing all the talking is
tommy but in fact it seems to me like
the scene is going to really be about
maya that the point of the scene is that
maya's getting fired
the other point about scene is that
she's getting fired unfairly
so
one of the most important things you
have to do with each scene is say what
is this actually about dramatically what
is the center of the scene the center of
the scene is maya's getting fired
unfairly now i would need to know the
rest of the story to really work it
because the truth is if maya's getting
fired unfairly and she is going to go
out and get a much better job in a
career that she really loves like a
paragliding teacher then this scene
would first of all be much shorter
because we don't really care why she got
fired unfairly so you'd want to just get
right to it in fact you know
most of the dialogue would go
but if the scene is about how
she's going to now try and find out who
did it and therefore it's going to get
into a thriller we would need to get
those details into the dialogue because
right now there isn't actually enough
specifics in tommy's accusation
so the first thing you need to do is
decide what the scene is about is it
about maya being motivated to
investigate maya being motivated to
change her life so we're talking about a
bigger question which is what's your
story about the scene is part of the
story you have to know what the story is
about then you can know what the scene
is about the scene is always about an
action currently the only person taking
an action in that scene is tommy maya
doesn't do anything except sit down
and so one of the things i would say is
if it's maya's story which seems like it
was from the
content of the scene
you would want to give her some action
it could be begging it could be
insisting that she'd be given a hearing
it could be trying to explain it it
could be turning on tommy and saying why
he thinks he's really doing it there's a
lot of possible scenes which give maya
an important action because really what
we want to know is what's maya going to
come out of this it could be that maya's
crushed
and it's going to we're going to see her
be miserable for a long time before she
discovers paragliding teacher
so
the the the dialogue it only
matters in the sense that it reflects
what the character is trying to
accomplish and what we are trying to
tell in terms of story for the character
so that's the first thing is
dialogue comes last
the next thing about the dialogue though
i would say is
you can be a lot shorter um
you know when she walked in just as a
dialogue lesson i would say he comes and
says maya sit down and then he says
names the the
websites and the type of website the
specific information would tell us a lot
about what this story is about assuming
it is the investigation or it's just he
says you know
i'm
sit down
you know
linens are us
vacations
unlimited and whatever it is we're
finding out about the person who did log
in
and it's also just more interesting
dialogue he just starts reciting these
weird things
or outrageous you know porn sites or
whatever it is terrorist sites
she's going to be like
i don't understand like she is but then
she's going to say
i saw freddie at my desk or someone at
my desk and you know that only
so and so has a key because they're my
superior whatever it is you're going to
be explaining the situation that sets up
the rest of the scene
and the rest of the
business terminology that was in the
scene
should go
unless
it is possible to make it a wonderfully
suspenseful
scene in which
tommy is just
blathering on with
you know corporate double speak and
we're getting tenser and tenser about
what's he getting to but then you would
build the scene a little differently his
speech would be more
tarantinoy in which he's playing little
mind games with her as he does it
so it's not impossible it's not like
there's an only one way to write a scene
you can play this scene with that kind
of long speech from tommy but then
tommy's got to have a reason that he's
doing it
the actual
corporate
liability not that important
i can keep going but i probably should
stop there no i love it so i think the
first thing then i need to determine
what is it that's going to happen to
maya from this
story what's the story then what's the
scene because the scene only exists
within a story
and with the story it's always going to
be for me the same six questions who is
it about
what do they want
why can't they get it
what do they do about that
why doesn't that work
what is the end and if you think about
in this case it's like well who is it
about it's about maya or tommy or maybe
it's about someone else about somebody
that you know takes maya's job and this
whole scene should just be maya you're
fired
um but let's assume the scene's about
maya so who is about maya what does she
want does she want to keep this job or
does she want to get a better life once
you've made that what's the obstacle the
obstacle of keeping the job is she got
fired unfairly the obstacle of the new
life is she wasn't prepared for this
she's broke
what does she do about that if
each one if she wants the job back she
has to find out who did this or find out
what tommy's up to or she would take
those actions
always asking
what is the story about and the story is
going to be about a character wanting
something
and so
story is about she needs this job she
has this son
and
you know she's kind of been left to pay
a bunch of bills and money's tight for
her and she doesn't like this job but
she really needs it
um
that's that's part of the story i guess
there has to be more of
what is going to happen to her life well
then you have to decide yeah in a big
picture what story do i want to tell do
i want to tell the story of someone who
takes on the corporate bad guys is it
about someone who
stumbles on a sinister plot
is it someone you know
whatever kind of story you want to tell
um is really going to make that
determination what kind of story do you
like if you like the sinister plot story
or if you like the she's going to team
up with a whole bunch of other people
who are unfairly fired and create their
own company you know i mean there's all
sorts of it could start be the start of
a comedy or it could be the start of a
thriller
right and so with the dialogue it should
be much more to the point don't worry
about the corporate double speak unless
i was really going to do
this crazy sort of tarantino ask in
theory less is more on dialogue but not
always some great long scenes exist it
just had better be worth it it better be
something that is creating some
set piece moment where something
extraordinary is happening not just a
big turning point but we're getting a
sense of the style of these characters
in this movie that's going to be all
about mind games or all about taking
down tommy because he's such an ass
right like glenn gary glenn ross exactly
those long scenes and and shows these
salesmen and kind of like what their
style was and
different things right and so this is
not that i don't think that there are
there's really any absolute rule like
keep dialogue short although in general
keep things short because
we like to move along but truthfully
it's more a matter of finding the model
that you are trying to be like if you're
saying yes i want to have a really
dialogue heavy
intricate character based drama
then keeping it short is not always to
your advantage it depends you just have
to make certain choices
everything is a choice and every choice
has a price you have to decide what type
of thing you're trying to do make the
choice to do that and then you build
every other thing based on those choices
how many times have you been hired by a
hollywood studio or producer where they
did not require you to outline for
writing a script
um
that's sort of tricky because i would
never not outline so therefore whether
they were required or not i was going to
do it the interesting thing is whether
or not they understood how much work an
outline is
because the truth is very often
in order to figure out the solutions to
a story to make the choices of a story
because that's really what figuring out
the solutions is is saying it's going to
be a story about this it's going to be a
story where this is the central action
that's the outlining process
and that's very very difficult that can
take as harder work than writing the
script and so everyone is always asking
you to essentially do that work before
they decide whether they're going to
hire you
although
things have changed a little bit but
truthfully most people assume that an
outline
is very short
and they did them in school so it's not
a big deal but an outline is really the
main
work of screenwriting and it can take
twice as long as writing the script
itself if you've got a good outline you
can write a script and it will go pretty
quickly
figuring out all the possible
shapes and choices of an outline that's
brutally hard
so the answer is
i would never take on a job that i
hadn't at least roughly outlined because
i wouldn't know that i could solve it
do people ask you to do outlines for
free yes should you do it for free no
um
it depends on where you are in your
career and what it's worth to you if you
want the experience of doing the outline
and you want to gain their trust but
don't do something you're going to
regret for free
i think that would be my advice on that
um
the other thing is um features
and shows are very different in shows
the outline breaking the story is a
required step for the company it's also
usually not done alone you don't usually
send one person off to do it although
sometimes you do uh depends on the
showrunner
but
outlining a show
is part of the
literally part of the job like you go
into the room you start by breaking the
story so um
nobody would ask you to do that without
being paid because you're already on the
job
do you have a proven style of outlining
that has worked for you the most it's
proven to me
um in the sense that yeah i think it's
great i've done a if you check out my
videos there's one called why outline
and one called how to outline the how-to
has the outline system
but basically what it really comes down
to is the important thing is to think in
scenes and write a a a written version
where you are
writing down the scenes in a list that's
what an outline is an outline is a list
of scenes
some people can do it on index cards
they even have index card software where
you can put a lot on it
i believe that the important thing is to
understand
that you are breaking a story into
scenes and then when you have your full
list of scenes and you know what
everything is going to happen in every
scene and there's nothing missing
then you're ready to write so that's the
importance of an outline the actual form
of it
it's whatever works for you
i believe that the most important thing
the thing to put in that first line the
the the headline of each outline step
is not where it takes place or even what
happens it's what is the essential
action the point of the scene so the
point of this like we were talking
before about a scene where maya gets
fired
the point of that scene is that maya
gets unfairly fired
you try to
make things active
always try to put things in active form
so maya gets fired is actually passive
she's getting fired the scene actually
is tommy fires maya unfairly now for me
that's a scene line because i know
exactly what the action is and i try to
always break it down to that sometimes
you know i'm the only one looking at it
oh that's the other thing outlines
should be for you
outlines are not to be read by other
people it's a workspace it's a workplace
if you have to do an outline for another
person that's a performance you should
copy your outline and then write a
version for other people to read but but
for you to work in an outline the
important thing is that you're doing
whatever will trigger you to understand
the point of the scene sometimes i know
a scene so well that i'll just write
joe drives to dallas now i know that
during the course of that he has to have
a breakdown but doesn't matter i know
what that means but really the scene is
joe has a breakdown while driving to
dallas the important thing is the
central action of the scene
and while there may be many steps in any
scene
there's usually one thing more than
anything else that that scene is about
and that's the point of the outline
then for me underneath it i'll put
everything i can think of i'll write
dialogue in my outline i'll do whatever
i can because i can always just cut and
paste it out later
but that space under the headline is
where you can ask yourself questions
you can and i write them in a different
color i write
why is joe having a breakdown how do we
know that joe is having a breakdown and
then i'll answer it
and i'll describe maybe i'll say like he
crumples up his hamburger and smashes it
into the rearview mirror whatever it is
i'm trying to get everything i can into
the outline so that i will know what it
is when i write the scene those outline
descriptions can be very long they can
be arguments with myself
the most important thing to do though is
break everything into a scene there's
nothing that is going to go into your
script that isn't in a scene so
the whole point of an outline is to get
you to remember if i don't have a scene
where that happens if i don't have a
scene where that subject is raised or
that feeling occurs
it's not going to be in the story
how common is it for you to write
backwards
i
always believe everyone should write
backwards but by that i do not mean you
actually start in the last scene and
write it right backwards i mean know the
ending that's really what right
backwards means
right backwards is a crucial thing
because until you know the ending you
don't actually know what your story is
about for instance
um
if
if you're telling a story in which
someone is trying to save their sister
from
lions
then
whether or not they actually do save
their sister and how they do it do they
do it by overcoming their fear of lions
or do they do it by learning lion
language and telling the lions to stop
that's going to be what the story is
about until you know that last thing the
thing that resolves the tension you
don't really know how to write anything
else so
work backwards really means
know your ending once you know the
ending
everything else makes sense in a
different way because you know that it's
an obstacle towards that or a step
towards that
when you were asked to take out that
core part of the one script
um did you go back to your outline and
you saw it there i don't know if it was
like the midpoint or where it was
and then try to reiterate like how did
when you went to that what was your
reaction to seeing that actually uh i i
totally failed on the first time i had
to do this so i'll tell you about the
second time when i succeeded at it but
the important thing is if you're taking
out the core of a story if you're
talking about the essential center of
the story it's not going to be in one
place the horrible thing the reason that
you can't do it is because it's in every
scene and that every single action the
person's taking is about a thing and if
they say let's not do that thing
then you're
really in trouble because you have to
rewrite everything
and worse than rewrite everything you
don't have any reason to do the other
thing
so you don't just tear it out you have
to replace it
i was working on a thriller it was about
a schizophrenic woman
living in new york she had just been
released from a mental hospital and
she's living in a crappy poor apartment
in hell's kitchen and the woman next
door to her is having an affair with a
police officer a street cop
and the
they have an argument the the lovers
have an argument and during the argument
they the woman grabs the cops gun it
goes off
and while he's trying to get it back and
he kills her
the schizophrenic woman hears all this
through the wall
and tries to leave
and when she does the cop sees her and
the rest of the thriller is
what's going to happen about that
i was in a very ornate 1970s
character-based kind of frame of mind so
not only did i add that but i added two
more characters one was an evil sergeant
who was
trying to force the cop who was actually
not a bad guy
to kill the witness
so the villain is actually
the murderer's boss
the woman
who has the witness has nowhere to go no
no one's gonna listen to her she's
schizophrenic she says she heard
something to the wall what you know
um
so the one person that she had to turn
to in my first draft of the story was a
guy who was an orderly
in the hospital where she was
and he was very kind to her
and she finds him and she tells him what
happened she asked for his help
that was a very ornate
complex set of relationships
and
jody foster's company
loved it but it was difficult and they
god bless them they gave me a lot of
money and a lot of time and they worked
with me and we worked on it
trying to figure out how to make it a
little more acceptable to the studio
system
um
and uh the executive there was meglifoe
who is now a phenomenal teacher and
writer um
and
we worked on it and she never asked the
thing that
i knew we needed
but she never said could we cut one of
these four characters
you've got a thriller with four main
characters
and i eventually said i think there's a
way to get rid of the guy that the
mentally ill person goes to now that
was taking out the core of the story
because by the end of the story they
have teamed up to defeat the evil
sergeant
and so i was removing the center of the
story
and
i had been asked before in other jobs to
remove the center of the story and it
just ruined my life so in this case i
thought you know
i asked the essential question what is
this story about and the story was about
this woman who knew that she had heard a
real thing but because of her disability
people were not taking her seriously and
the people who
were taking her seriously were trying to
kill her right
she's the center of the story
and i had divided her action among two
people i thought that was cool as a
writing exercise it is cool as a movie
for jody foster it's not cool it was a
dumb choice but on the other hand when i
wrote it jody foster wasn't going to do
it so
once i moved into that position i
thought you know what this
woman's character needs to hold the
whole story on herself and the
relationship really is about her and the
poor policemen in between her and the
villain
so from a four-way story i made it a
three-way story
it was better it was a better version
now i had worked really hard on the
four-way version and i loved it
and i was very proud of myself for
recognizing
that there are even with something that
is
like i think it's great the original
version but it's not the only way to do
it and that was a real breakthrough for
me to recognize that something that i
loved and felt right
also had another version that i loved
and eventually felt was even more right
the triangle version was much more
powerful and the characters became much
more interesting
so
how do you do it you look at what is the
real center of the story the center of
the story was this woman that because of
her disability
had very limited ability to defend
herself or get help
and how she found the resources of
communicating with people
to solve that problem
did the film ever get made with another
last no it didn't and they tried they
tried so hard they were wonderful um
they they did but it was just a really
hard project at a really
hard time and there's a lot of times
when something you don't get all the
pieces together and if you follow the
trades you'll often see this happening
where
a passion project for someone
but it requires
to get
the right alignment of stars and
financing and all these other things
have to come together and everyone has
to believe in it for all their own
reasons
it's a frankly a astonishing that
anything gets made at all
i would watch that movie me too yeah
yeah that's well it's that's
powerful
but um but the answer is how do you
remove the center of your story and the
answer is
you look for where it is in the story
and you'll usually find
it's it's not where you're the thing
you're clinging to
because the thing you're clinging to is
clearly making people uncomfortable and
if enough people are telling you
something is not working for them
you have to come to a choosing point you
have to say
i want it to work for me and i don't
care about anybody else
but if enough if a lot of people are
saying i really love this but it's not
working in this way you have to think
about is there something about that that
you can rethink
the other thing is sometimes you have to
remove the heart of your story and then
you better just replace it find a new
heart find a new core to the story that
works well
and the story will keep living
wow that was like so metaphorically
well-turned yeah
with with this story was was the
schizophrenic woman was it her journey
out of
um the hospital into quote normalized
life or was it also getting people to
regard her as that was actually one of
the big problems was it was very
important to me to fairly portray
what often is not shown in movies most
movies are like well if they could just
get sympathy they'd be cured
and the reality of her illness was that
she was not going to get all over it
with an insight she had a serious mental
illness and the question was how can she
communicate and gain others trust and
learn to trust them in order to get help
and so one of the hardest things was
essentially a lot of people wanted it to
become
a story about someone who's a
neglected action hero and and that's not
what what the company wanted you know
they really respected the point of the
script and certainly not what i intended
i wanted to try and
talk about what it's like
to have a mental illness and need to
work
with it